my passion runs deep for the rock okay  so you're saying that you rock harder is  that what you're saying let me just tell  you something I rock way way way harder  [Laughter]  no no now we rock harder much harder no  no no no no no I say - no way what did  you just say I just I'm sorry did  [ __ ] just crawl to your ears you  shall learn not to disrespect the D you  have issued a clear invitation to the  dance  yes no wait stop guys guys come on what  what is it Andy why don't you just  settle it with the guitar off  a guitar  [Applause]  hacks  alright let's get this thing going  alright begin yeah why don't you start  it off we'll just see who  [Applause]  [Music]  yeah  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  sorry I'm sorry I got really insecure  I'm sorry  I want to thank slash for helping me out  [Applause]  you